I think politics was getting very
insular and it's not of course it's not
just us the the technology the
communications technology has enabled
new groups new actors to be involved in
politics and bring a much more diverse
group of folks into the mix I believe
that politics was getting too insular
you had this the sense of a broadcast
politics where a few elites in
Washington discuss to discuss things and
dinner parties perhaps and then that
became the story of the day and in the
broadcast media and what we really
watched all of America really watched
politics for was the the game the horse
race not not how we're actually solving
the problem to all things
you